- First off,
if--if your 50-year-old husband
comes in and says
he wants to start a ska band,
just take him to rehab,
just right away.
Just take him--if anyone wants
to start a ska band today,
fucking take them to rehab.
Bad time.
[dark electronic music]
♪
[man roars]
[both snarling]
[dark electronic music]
♪
[man grunting]
[gunshots]
[dark electronic music]
[zombie growls]
[gun cocks]
[gunshot]
♪
- Ladies and gentlemen,
he's got his own podcast
called "Keeping 'Em Alive."
Please give it up for
Mr. Greg Behrendt, everybody.
Let him hear it.
[dark electronic music]
♪
- I love this show.
And I love the idea that--
that you have an experience
where you're like,
"This is not happening, right?"
Like, just, "This is fucked up."
You know, we all have
those stories.
I mean, I have a--
I have a ton of them.
One I'm not telling today,
I saw the penis of the drummer
from Meta--
like at a show.
That's not happ--No.
I mean, like you can't
wrap your head
or anything around it;
it's huge.
But also, sometimes you forget
that you're the thing
that's happening
to somebody else.
Like, you're the fucking "oh,
my God, this is not happening."
Like, you're the event that
somebody goes, "Fuck...
You."
So I would like
to tell you a story
that has both of those elements,
uh, and it involves my sobriety,
which I have today,
uh, and I've had since 1996,
except for the two times
that I got high, which--
So that--
that means not since 19--
so I broke it,
but that's 'cause the--
that's not the rules.
So you don't get to just leave.
Well, you can, and I have.
But one time,
it was my decision,
and the other time,
it was also my decision.
So the--the first story--
the first story is this one.
So my wife and I, uh,
we had a, uh,
a 19-year-old dog, okay?
Fucking 19-year-old
German Shepherd.
That is fucking old.
Like, that is--that's done.
Like, that dog is fucking done.
Like, it literally just
sat in the corner
of a room, it was like
a fucking pillow
with bones in it and a head.
It just sat there.
Like, the dog wanted
to be done.
Do you understand? Like, it was
just being kept alive on pills.
That's it--we just
gave it pills
to fucking keep it alive.
And you know, they're fuck--
they don't--
you know, they're not--
well, they are dumb,
but they're not that dumb.
You know what I mean?
Like, the dog was just, like--
you could just tell--
it was like, "Fuck, dude.
"Haven't we done this?
"Haven't I dogged
the shit out of it?
"What the fuck do you want
from me?
"Fuck, I got the ball.
Remember that?
"I got it a bunch of times,
as I recall,
"and I fucking shit
on the carpet
"and ruined that whole fucking
birthday party thing,
"and then I took a picture
for your fucking Instagram.
Please. What the fuck more do
you want from me?" Right?
But you don't kill it
'cause it's a dog.
So like, here, take these pills.
We just gave it a lot of pills,
right?
So anyway, we had this dog
and it was very old
and it was being kept alive
on pills.
So, uh, uh--and
I didn't know what the pill--
I didn't pay any attention
what the pills were.
I mean, I had--there was one--
that dog had no moves left,
right?
Except for that they--
except it would fart. Right?
It'd just go, "Oh."
You know what I mean?
But their butt holes
are all worked out
so it just--you don't even know
it's happened.
You know, their butt holes
are all loose.
So it's just "Ooh."
It just comes out.
It's like a cloud.
Like, "Ooh."
Like, it just, "Ooh."
It's just like ghost farts.
It's just a whistle,
like you don't know it's there
until you know it's there,
and then you're fucking pissed.
'Cause dog farts are like--
like, you know how some smells,
you go, "Ugh!"
But dog farts make you pissed.
Like, you're like, "Fuck!
"What the fuck is this?
"Jesus Christ!
Good god.
What the fuck's wrong with you?"
So anyway, uh,
there was one Christmas.
Uh, I love Christmas.
I fucking love it.
I like Christmas so much, I'm
gonna make you fucking hate it.
That's how much I like it.
I'm that guy.
I like it so much,
I ruin it for my whole family,
which is fucked up
'cause I have kids.
Anyway, so I have that.
It's Christmas, and uh,
I'm overexcited about it,
and I'm also depressed,
uh, because I have depression
and anxiety,
which I'm not aware of.
And also, there was a sweater
I wanted
and I'm not fucking getting it.
Like, even when my wife said,
"You're not getting it,"
I'm like, "Like,
in a surprise way?
Or I'm not fucking getting it?"
And not in a surprise way.
And then she's like,
"It should be about the kids."
Fuck you.
I dog-eared the catalog.
And then she's like, "I don't
even know what a catalog is
'cause I live in the now."
The point is,
I was very upset,
and it was Christmas Eve
and I was sort of--
I was having a panic attack
and feeling shitty,
and not to get too dark,
but I was feeling, uh, suicidal.
I was struggling with
some mental health issues
that I didn't know that I had,
and anxiety,
and, um, uh,
and then all of a sudden,
I remembered that one day,
when my friend was in the house,
he had walked past
the dog pills,
and he had noticed
that one of the jars of pills
was like, "Oh, my--oh, fuck,
you have those."
You know what I mean?
He didn't say what they were,
but he made a face that went,
"That's good."
Like, there's something
in those pills
that might be something
a depressed person should take
on Christmas Eve.
So there were two jugs of--
and dog pills come in, like,
little, tiny jugs,
like tankards,
not the tall orange ones.
So thanks for clearing that up,
Greg.
You're welcome.
I walk past the dog pills.
I remember that one of them is
potent, apparently,
and I'm not sure which,
'cause I also know
the other one's
for the butt hole.
So I don't want to take--
I don't want to take
the wrong one.
My butt hole's tight and--
you know what I mean?
I don't need a fucking really--
My sphincter's good enough.
I don't need to really--
You know what I mean?
It's for a dog that has--
Anyway, so...
Then there's a--there's a--
there's a--there--
on one of the jugs,
there's the sleepy-faced guy.
Do you know the sleepy-faced guy
on the pills?
Right, he's like--he's got,
like, a nose,
and then he's like, "Oh."
He's so tired
'cause he's taking these pills
and he's not allowed
to operate machinery.
Do you know what
I'm talking about? That guy.
If that guy's on a jar of pills,
fucking ta--
if you want to party,
but don't--
I'm saying no to drugs.
But if you're depressed
and you don't know any better,
that's the one you go for.
And also,
but why would a dog's pills
have a sleeping--what did they--
what is it they have to stay
awake for?
Do you know what I mean?
If your dog's operating
any machinery,
you don't understand pets
at all.
Or you're missing
a really fucking good
financial opportunity,
'cause fuck.
Your dog can drive a forklift.
So I take one of the pills.
I'm not really sure what it is,
but I take one of the pills.
And then I read the j--
and I--and it fucking--
it's like a sweater
for your insides.
It's magical.
It levels me out.
I'm like, oh, my God.
This is amazing.
Something called
hydrocodone, right?
And I--and as an alcoholic,
I'm like,
I'm never doing that again.
Just the one time.
Just gonna do it the one--
just the one--
next week,
I'll take one other one.
Later in the month, then two,
maybe--five a day.
So like an alcoholic
drug addict,
I escalated, and by that--
then, I was taking
seven a day, and at that point,
I just had lost--it--
[sighs] fuck, one day--
here's a perfect example.
One day, I just fucking
showed up in the kitchen
of my own house with a--
I had cut myself a Mohawk,
and told my wife
I was starting a ska band.
If--that, guys--
if you--first off,
if--if your 50-year-old husband
comes in and says
he wants to start a ska band,
just take him to rehab,
just right away.
Just take him--if anyone wants
to start a ska band today,
fucking take them to rehab.
Bad time.
It's been played out, all right?
So I was super fucked up
and I did try and
start a ska band because--
and I quit my other really
reliable jobs;
comedy and writing books.
So...
I'd given up
those opportunities.
Uh, my wife was very upset.
I was a total fucking mess.
They took me to rehab.
So now, I go to rehab.
I pull my shit together.
I move back in the house.
I can't live in the house.
They put me in a--
I have a--we have a guesthouse,
in a garage.
I live in the garage.
There's a place--
It was on the other side
of the ho--yard.
I lived in a closet on the other
side of the yard,
but I--
Right?
Hey, good night, everybody!
Anyone?
So, uh, uh--
But I was living there.
But I really was, like, okay,
I'm gonna pull it together.
I got on the right kind
of medication
and I figured out that
I had some problems,
and pulling my life together,
and I'm feeling good.
And I kind of miss
the ska band.
I really did want
to be a rock star.
You know what I mean?
But I had to give up the--
you know what I mean?
Not for--I mean,
not that anyone noticed,
but anyway, so...
I start working on my standup
and my career.
I write a one-man show.
I make friends with
my wife again--just friends.
Anyway, I, um, uh,
I get my shit together
and I'm feeling very good
about myself,
because now I'm not the thing
that happens to you, right?
I'm the guy experiencing life.
I'm not gonna ruin
people's lives.
I'm gonna be of service.
I'm gonna be a good person.
I'm just gonna fucking just--
you know,
just take it day-by-day,
have everything--
You know, and things are good.
My career's coming back.
My wife likes me again.
I get asked to go to Australia
to perform for 22 nights in--
in Melbourne.
Uh, a one-man show
that I've written.
Very exciting.
Career's on the comeback.
Got a big tour after that.
It's all good.
I have a little stomachache.
It's fine.
It's a little stomachache.
I went to the doctor before
I left for Australia.
He said it was gas.
That's not good doctoring
when you find out what it was.
Eight shows into
my run in Australia,
uh, I'm on fire.
My insides are burning.
It's awful.
I go to the doctor,
they give me some drugs,
which I--oh, my gosh.
I remember these.
Uh, they had to--they had to
give me some drugs
because I was in so much pain,
I forgot even about drugs.
I forgot that there were--like,
I was in "Kill me" pain.
I was literally like the dog--
just end this.
Just fucking end it.
I was in so much pain.
They give me, um,
I don't know, whatever.
Some sort of pain reliever.
And then they take a photo
of my insides,
and then they wake me up,
and they say,
"You have tumors in your
stomach--you have cancer."
Fuck.
I was on my way to a comeback.
Um, so that's what they said.
You have a--
but it was in Australia,
so I have to say,
and I'm not saying get cancer.
I'm against it.
I'm against cancer.
I just want to come out right
now and say I'm against cancer.
I don't want you to get it.
Should you think you have it,
go to Australia
to get the diagnosis,
because just the way
they say "cancer"
sounds a tiny bit less bad.
That's all. "Cancer."
It just goes up at the end.
It just--"Cancer, mate.
You have cancer, mate."
They say "mate" a lot.
It just feels cheerier,
like you're doing it together.
"Hey, you got cancer, mate."
"We all do?"
"No, you do."
Anyway, cancer. They told me.
I had it.
Uh, they thought I did.
I had tumors in my stomach,
they weren't sure what they
were, but they were--
there was a cluster of tumors,
right?
Just really--a lot of Rs.
A lot of--
You find out there's a lot of Rs
in cancer.
"Cluster," "tumor"--
lot of Rs.
So I-I--
They think I have cancer,
and they say,
"You have to go home,"
and I was so high
on whatever it was they gave me,
I'm like,
"To my apartment in Australia?"
And they go, "No, to America."
You have to take
your cancer home.
You have to take it home.
Can't have it there.
They--they don't want you
dying there.
So, um, uh,
so I say, "All right."
And they, uh, they say,
"But you're gonna be in pain
"until you get to the hospital.
"You need to get there within
the next 72 hours.
But here is a box of OxyContin."
I'm like, that could
be a mistake.
A box.
Not just a few.
A fucking box.
Like, with trays.
Do you understand?
We're talking about
a street value
of about a million dollars!
To a drug addict!
Who's already high from whatever
it is they gave them--
I went out and bought a hat.
So...
Here's how high I was.
I had my manager with me.
I said, "Take the pills.
"Give 'em to me, and let's be
responsible about this.
"I just want to get home.
I want to see my family.
If I'm gonna die, fair enough,
but I just want to get home."
So, uh, I go, uh, to, uh,
the airport,
and everything's fine, except
for I accidently put a knife
in my backpack.
That's--you don't--
you're not allowed to take
a knife through customs.
I don't know if I'm sharing
anything new with you guys,
but no knives at customs
on an international flight.
They don't care for it.
So I had a knife in my backpack,
and the lady goes--
she was very nice,
and she said,
"Sir, this is a knife."
And I said to her,
"I have cancer."
She literally goes,
"Uh..."
I don't know
what the next sentence is.
Like, literally, I don't know
what to say to you.
So she's like, "Well, you still
have to leave the knife,
but I'll give you a hug."
So...
My--my manager's with me,
so that's my thing.
I'm like, "Just make sure
"that I don't overuse
the drugs, 'cause I could,
"and because I'm dying,
I probably don't care.
"So make me care and don't let
me take all the drugs,
'cause I don't want to show up
at home being that guy."
So I get on the airplane,
and they stick my manager
in fucking economy
and they put me in first class,
so I know I'm dying, right?
I know it's a Make-A-Wish thing.
"Put him in first class,
it's probably the last time
he'll be on a plane."
So they throw him
in fucking baggage
and I'm sitting in a throne or
a--you know, whatever it is.
Just this massive thing
where they give you backrubs.
And I'm sitting next to a guy
who I don't know,
who turns out to be this drummer
for the band Switchfoot.
Do you guys know
Switchfoot at all?
Yeah? Yeah?
That's usually
the response I get.
Yeah...
So, uh, anyway--
they're a fine band,
they're a fine band.
I don't know them,
but I know who they are.
But I--I know that they surf,
and I know they're Christian,
and that's all I know.
Probably couldn't sing a song,
but the guy's super nice,
the drummer,
and so we start talking,
I say, "Look, I'm gonna ask you
a really weird favor,
"but I'm dying--maybe--
probably--
"and, uh, I have to take
these pills,
"and would you give them to me
and not let me
"take more than I need
and make sure
I take them when
I'm supposed to?"
And he said, "Yeah, sure."
I said, "Thank you."
Also, if I get up--
like, if I rub your chest
or walk around the plane, or--
I don't know if any of you have
ever been on OxyContin,
but it's not bad.
Yeah, you feel--
you're friendly,
and you like conversations,
and you want to talk to everyone
about everything, and you also--
It has this amazing thing
that never happens to me
in real life--it actually makes
you want to listen to people.
So...
Like, you're genuinely
interested in weird shit.
What kind of buttons are those?
"On my--on my shirt?"
Yeah. They seem neat.
All right.
Anyway, the guy was super nice
and I said, "Would you make sure
I don't overuse these?"
And then I passed out
and I slept the whole flight.
You know.
Uh, and, uh,
so, we get to Los Angeles,
and, uh--and uh,
so it's cool.
I'm sitting next to a guy
from a band.
That's neat, and he says,
"Let me walk
you to baggage claim."
So the drummer from Switchfoot
walks me to baggage claim,
gets my bags for me,
and then he goes,
"Hey, man, I just want to tell
you that I love you.
"I said a prayer for you.
You're gonna be fine."
And I was like, wow.
And I bent down
to pick up my bags,
and I turned around,
and he was fucking gone.
Gone--not, like,
oh, in a crowd.
Like, fucking--
there was nobody--
he was gone!
I was like, fuck!
Did I dream that?
Were these my last moments?
I had a lucid dream?
Why the guy from Switchfoot?
Thank you.